hey guys it's Justine and today we have
all of the brand new iPhone 14 pluses in
the studio and we're gonna check them
out I am so excited as you guys know the
new iPhone 14 has been released we have
the iPhone 14 pro the iPhone 14 pro Max
the iPhone 14 and the iPhone 14 plus
which was the one that they were
releasing later on after the other
iPhone 14s and they're here so we have
all of the colors we've got the midnight
we've got the blue the red the purple
and the Starlight and we also have some
accessories we've got all of these cases
to check out as well so we'll see how
these match up with the iPhone 14 plus
we have the midnight the blue the red
the purple and the Starlight let's unbox
foreign
[Music]
midnight looking extra shiny look at
that beauty
so the iPhone 14 pluses obviously are
the bigger version of the iPhone 14 and
this is a new size for them in that
range I do have a full video review on
all of the iPhone 14s if you want to
check that out I'll put a link in the
description the real difference though
is of course if you do want to have the
telephoto lenses the iPhone 14 models do
not have telephoto they do only have the
two cameras and they also don't have the
dynamic Island so they do still have the
Notch from the previous versions one
down four to go
[Music]
foreign
I did have the 14 in this blue color and
it is just so pretty this might be one
of my favorite colors look at it it's so
great it's like the most perfect baby
blue color so here it is so here's the
size difference between the 14 plus and
the 14. you can see there is a pretty
significant size difference and this
really does make a difference when you
are using these devices for browsing for
reading and for text messages and things
like that like that little bit of screen
real estate does go a long way and then
here's the plus next to the iPhone 14
pro Max so you can tell that obviously
it is missing one of the camera lenses
but it is pretty much the same size as
that device now it's time to open up the
product red let's check it out it's
always interesting to see the different
colors of the product red because they
always do vary slightly between the
different models
whoa this is like okay so I saw this at
the event but for some reason I don't
remember being so vibrant this is like
it's like almost like hurting my eyes
like I can't even focus on the red it's
like a it's so bright I love it this
could quite possibly be my favorite ride
that they've ever done
they've got the product Red Label no red
sticker though this red is awesome I
can't get over it I just want to keep
staring at it it looks so good so from
the archives we have pulled the iPhone 8
plus now this is a deep red color which
I actually also really like so bright
what a great red I was like if we just
take a moment to appreciate the tiny
little camera let's look at it look at
those rounded edges on that eight time
for purple
oh it's such a nice like light purple
like a beautiful lavender lilac so this
purple is a very light purple color so
it's not like the super deep purple that
is the iPhone 14 pro Max
here is with both of the purples look
like next to each other very very
different purples got our deep purple
and our not deep purple at all both
beautiful devices it may be hard to tell
in this light because the studio lights
are very very bright but it is in fact
purple just a very light purple now it's
time for Starlights
foreign
so the Starlight is such an interesting
color because it's not quite silver but
it's also not quite gold it's Starlight
so it does have a very warm hint to it
but yet it's not silver it's not tan I
don't even know what color it is so it's
so hard to even explain what the color
is like unless you actually see it
this looks nice I really like this color
see this I feel like would be the color
that I would have gotten if I was
getting the iPhone 14 plus because I
couldn't decide if I wanted the silver
or the gold and I wouldn't have had to
have decide I would have basically have
gotten both Best of Both Worlds right
here so you can tell along the aluminum
edge that this is a little bit more of a
warmer color
so it's not quite silver not quite gold
so we have the gold iPhone 13 and the
silver iPhone 14 so you can see the
colors between them is it's basically
like right in the middle put those two
together you've got Starlight so here's
all of the colors all lined up so we've
got our midnight our blue our red our
Starlight and our purple and I'm curious
for you guys which color is your
favorite I think if I had to pick I
think it's going to be the blue there's
something about this blue that's like so
beautiful it's baby blue but yet it has
a little bit more saturation I do like
these phones when they have like a
brighter color like I like that these
are kind of a soft a little more muted a
little light but these ones are like
super aggressive and like high hello we
have bright colors over here so these
two I think are actually my favorite the
red and the blue it is also kind of
crazy because having these all together
you can actually see the color
differences the star like next to the
purple it really does show off more of
the purple tape into this phone now
let's open up the cases and see what
they look like on all of the phones
I love this color it's so dark it's
almost like a black so if you were
looking to get like a dark color case
the midnight is pretty close to a black
color
nice
storm blue
yeah I like the storm blue color this is
probably my favorite combo look how good
it looks
[Music]
red on red that looks fresh yup that
looks so nice like I love these matching
Reds like they did a really great job on
the red this year okay now we've got one
of the leather cases for the Starlight
[Music]
actually pretty nice what a nice combo
this gives giving me some like serious
Western Vibes like where's my cowboy hat
that's fresh look at that
last one we've got the purple
I'm so sad when I went to the Apple
Store I bought one of these but I bought
it for the wrong phone so
I need to go return it so I can actually
get the right size for my phone
purple
yes yes love this this combo also
fantastic they did a really great job
color matching which I guess it's it's
Apple so they have that ability and here
we have it our full lineup with their
cases I think they all look great okay
so now other question what is your
favorite case combo I'm gonna say
I think the purple the purple looks
great I like that purple purple combo
they look really good well this is just
the first look at some of the colors I
do have a bunch more iPhone videos that
I have made over the past few weeks so
if you guys want to check those out I
will put them here on the end screen but
I'd love to hear from you guys though in
the comments below let me know who got
an iPhone 14 this year is this something
that you've been waiting for have been
waiting for the plus I am pretty excited
about this lineup I think it's really
great that they did decide to do a
larger model I know there are a lot of
people who are upset that they didn't
decide to do a mini version this year
but instead they went the opposite
direction we now have a larger plus
lineup so thank you again for watching I
will see you guys in my next video if
you haven't already Please Subscribe hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos and I will see you in the next
one bye
[Music]